[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up remember glasgow
six months on a desperate plea for
action from the host of the cop26
climate summit
leaders have not done enough to deliver
on their glasgow commitments
and that must change
greenpeace protesters arrested after
blocking a tanker of russian diesel from
docking in the thames
and will the big plastic count help the
uk get to grips with its pollution
problem
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
solutions
now six months ago today the eyes of the
world were on glasgow where negotiations
continued well beyond deadlines to
hammer out a deal on climate change that
nearly 200 countries could agree to
since then though the world has been
distracted by the war in ukraine above
all else and climate targets seem to be
taking a back seat
well the meeting's host alok sharma
today pleaded with world leaders not to
lose focus
climate change is a chronic danger
a danger that will be with us for
generations to come and so we must
continue to confront it as we also deal
with the pressures
of the present
that is why it is imperative we deliver
the glasgow climate pact
but frankly we need to up the pace
leaders have not done enough to deliver
on their glasgow commitments
and that must change
so let's remind ourselves of what the
key cop 26 pledges were well the glasgow
agreement called on countries to phase
down unabated coal power now that was
crucial because it was the first time
that coal had even been mentioned in
this sort of agreement
countries also promised to phase out
inefficient fossil fuel subsidies now
that's a reference to reducing
dependence on oil and gas
the pact agreed to keep the goal of
limiting global warming to 1.5 degrees
above pre-industrial levels to keep that
within reach
while stopping deforestation
accelerating the move to clean cars and
providing finance for poorer countries
to shift away from fossil fuels
so what's happened since last november
well our science and technology editor
tom clark joins me now so tom real
concern about progress since last
november and some even worried about us
slipping backwards
that's absolutely right and of course a
lot has happened and the the most
significant thing of course when it
comes to
energy is the war in ukraine and the
impact that that's had on economies and
on economies spheres of where they're
going to get energy from
uh for the next
potentially
several years at least you know alex
sharma today warning that it would be in
his words an act of monstrous self-harm
not to deliver on the pledges at cop26
nicholas sturgeon is on a visit to the
us she of course was the the host of the
of the glasgow summit she warned again
it would be a catastrophic failure uh if
we if we didn't deliver on cop 26 but
the reality is
people are thinking about other things
right now leaders are thinking about
other things and not only that with
prices very very high fossil fuel
companies are making big big profits
that's been in the headlines of course
in recent weeks they're pouring those
profits into more exploration because of
course people are looking for
alternative sources the concern being if
we've got more low-cost fossil fuels in
a few years time as a result of that
will it make these gains harder not to
mention the fact while that's been going
on china and india have been increasing
coal use to to fuel their economies
uh making it potentially harder to make
progress and also it's the ambition that
that sort of inertia that momentum that
was set up at cop26 have we dropped off
the pace one thing observers have said
though
big government governments and big
economies have had an opportunity here
to turn away to backslide on climate
commitments so far we haven't seen that
happening at least in the words that
they're speaking the actions will
obviously have to come and we'll have to
watch those closely as cop 27
comes around in november well yes not
long until cop 27 how much pressure does
it put on countries to to make the right
kind of commitments and make real
changes before then
i mean a huge amount of pressure because
i think i think everyone would agree
this has certainly
been a major distraction what's happened
in ukraine since then and the fact
there's a slowdown in the in the real
economy in the china in china us talking
about recession as well we need to make
investments to obviously chart that net
zero progress
uh the reality too
that not one of the 10 biggest economies
has increased its commitment so far on
reducing uh greenhouse gas cuts but
they've got to do before we get to
charmel shake in the autumn one one
tailwind that we've got however higher
energy prices while they are going to be
crippling for consumers of difficult
time are going to focus minds on net
zero so there is a lot of incentive now
of course to pursue those alternatives
is there the cash is there momentum is
there the attitude all the while let's
not forget co2 emissions have actually
been accelerating since the last climate
summit serve methane emissions so is
deforestation the amazon so there's an
awful lot to play for here
tom thank you
now let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now and
conservationists are warning that
invasive foreign species are threatening
the uk's wildlife the wildlife and
countryside link has published a list of
10 native species it considers most at
risk from disease competition or being
eaten by so-called invasive hitchhikers
that includes red squirrels earthworms
and juniper trees experts are now
calling for improved biosecurity
measures to prevent harmful species from
entering the country
new zealand's government has announced a
292 million pound trial program to help
lower income families scrap their old
cars and replace them with cleaner
hybrid or electric vehicles it's part of
a larger scheme to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions in line with pledges made
under the 2016 paris agreement the
government has also set a target of
reducing total car travel by 20 percent
over the next 13 years
major world cities risk running out of
fresh water as a result of climate
change a new report by christian aide
found that urban centres including
london beijing and new delhi face
increasing pressure on resources from
growing populations more than half of
the world's population live in cities
and that number is expected to reach 68
by
2050. greenpeace protesters have blocked
a tanker containing russian diesel from
entering a port in essex activists
climbed onto a jetty where the tanker
was due to dark forcing it to turn
around in the thames
eight people have been arrested on
suspicion of aggravated trespass the
government has banned russian ships from
entering the uk but the tanker was
traveling under a greek flag
now the energy regulator ofgem has today
announced that the price cap will be
updated every three months in an attempt
to pass on wholesale prices more quickly
critics say it could lead to yet more
price rises for hard hit consumers
let's just take a look then at our data
dashboard and these numbers here tell us
where our electricity comes from at any
given time and right now you can see
that half is coming from gas around half
and a third also is coming from
renewables now the majority of that is
coming from wind with some of it coming
from solar power
and then look at this over the last week
about a third of our power has come from
wind
with solar pushing renewables up to well
over 40 percent of the mix and looking
back further over the past month
gas has made up a bigger proportion over
half of the mix as you can see here with
just over a quarter coming from
renewables
well over the past year these are the
numbers gas at around 40 percent there
and we still use some coal
but it's just under two percent and
renewables that's mainly wind and solar
make up about a quarter with nuclear
also low carbon making up about 17
percent and all of this is important
because as the economy decarbonizes the
amount of electricity that we use will
go up for electric vehicles for example
and the national target is for the grid
to decarbonize by 2035 now that's just
13 years for the gas and the coal to
disappear from this picture completely
now despite talking about plastic
pollution and recycling for years now
the uk produces more plastic waste per
head than any other country in the world
by the united states
so this week around 140 000 people are
recording how much plastic they throw
away and this is an attempt to encourage
government and supermarkets to do more
to tackle the problem well broadcaster
and naturalist uh chris packham joins me
now he's part of this campaign so tell
us a bit more this is about asking
people to record the plastics that
they're throwing away isn't it so what's
the purpose of that what will that
information do
well it's a piece of citizen science
that's been put together by greenpeace
and everyday plastic and it's actually
up to 180 000
uh sign ups now and throughout the
course of this week monday through to
sunday we're asking people to sort
through all of the plastic waste which
they use in their homes and identify
what it is and if you sign up at
thebigplasticcount.com you can download
a sheet or you can do it online where
you separate these into various
categories of plastic and the use that
they have
it's an audit into our plastic waste
so that we can better inform the
government that's going through a
process this year of setting targets to
reduce the amount of uh plastic that we
use in our packaging and so on and so
forth um so that we can get this
genuinely good data so that we can ask
them to make better informed decisions
what we do know at the moment is that
our recycling system is essentially
broken we are producing
a lot of material that needs recycling
i'm very sad to tell you that more of
that that we sought in our homes to be
recycled is shipped overseas either to
go into landfill or be burned then it is
recycled in the uk so it's clear that
despite all of our awareness when it
comes to plastic waste we're still
producing an enormous quantity of it and
we're still not getting it into a state
where we can reuse it rather than
recycle it and this data will help us
set new targets we hope so that we can
improve the situation and it's
staggering isn't it that we're second
only to the us in terms of plastic
pollution so
how do we go about changing it
well i think again another aspect of
citizen science projects like this is
that all of those who take part are
you know given no choice but think about
the plastic waste that they have in
their house i've got a separate bag now
for this week and i'm putting all my
paper in one into that recycling bag and
all the plastics in the other and come
sunday i shall sort through it and
categorize it all and that will be a
moment of awareness for myself as it
were all of the other participants i
think you're right it is rather
staggering that we are second only to
the united states but i guess we've just
grown complacent to the fact that we go
into our supermarkets particularly when
it comes obviously to food packaging um
and there's a lot of it there it's snuck
up on us and and we've grown into a a
lifestyle where we've come to accept
that there is all of this plastic
packaging most of which isn't recyclable
and doesn't get recycled even if you and
i sought it so
you know what it's like it's it's that
complacency you think that's just the
way we live well i can remember when it
wasn't the way we lived and there were
plenty of people who helped out there
who have a better design of the way that
we should be living and could be living
at this point in time in a far more
sustainable
and and harmonious way with the
environment so this sort of audit is not
just about generating data it's about
opening people's eyes to the impact that
they're having when it comes to plastic
and potentially plastic pollution
really interesting chris beckham always
pleasure to have you on the program
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thank you chris packham there now i'm
going to be joined in the next few
minutes by climate activist laura young
and navrav singhali a lecturer in
climate law and we're going to be
discussing progress following cop26 and
also how to make progress on that issue
we're just talking about plastic
pollution
[Music]
independent united kingdom
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power
you must stay at home and it's my job to
figure out how these decisions made by
politicians
impact all of us in our everyday lives
this is the worst thing i've ever been
through in my life people turn up here
with their child stuff in a black sack
and just say i don't want him and that
is what it is he's first-class poverty
is this an example of the welfare state
failing
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world these are stories
that affect us all
millions of children are now having to
catch up
some stories have changed all of our
lives because like the residents the
staff are being infected politicians
they make decisions all of the time and
it's our job to hold them to account i
wonder if you will take this opportunity
to apologize to those families but in
the end the real power doesn't actually
lie with the politicians
the real power
lies with the people
i'm nick martin i'm the people and
politics correspondent at sky news
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to some of those
climate issues now with climate activist
laura young and navrav singhali lecturer
in climate law so very good evening to
both of you nice to see you both
so it feels like only yesterday that we
were all in glasgow bringing you
hour-by-hour updates on negotiations on
the glasgow climate pact but it's
actually six months on and it's fair to
say the world's focus has shifted well
alex sharma and nicolas sturgeon today
both called for renewed attention on
climate action and laura how badly do
you think that's needed what's happened
since cop 26. has the world's attention
do you think shifted away from climate
issues
i think it has and i think one of the
problems is we have shifted our thoughts
to many other issues but forgotten that
many of them relate to climate change or
will be exacerbated by climate change or
impact climate change so we really need
to get our head screwed on a little bit
more and think about it and i think your
question at the beginning is right what
has happened over the last six months it
feels like a lot of back tracking has
happened it feels like there is a lot of
hypocrisy and it feels like there's a
lot of disagreement everyone seemed to
be all on the same page when cop 26 was
in glasgow but now it seems like people
have gone back to their old ways or are
now fighting a different cause and
trying to take us in a different
direction than we need to be going in
but navraj the world is a different
place isn't it the uh
russia's invasion of ukraine has shifted
the dial completely and some countries
might be making some short-term
decisions to address this issue of
weaning themselves off russian oil and
gas which may not be good for the
environment but it's completely
understandable also given that the cost
of living crisis too
sure um
well in one way i think the world is not
a different place we live in a world of
permanent crises whether it's
large-scale military interventions or
global pandemics or before that global
financial crises and so on and so forth
so
you cannot defer climate action for a
nice stable point in time when it
becomes easy because it's never going to
be easy
so that's really wishful thinking
and this the second point is that if you
make
policy or strategies to
respond to
the
uh ukraine intervention
and climate change right now
by the time these policies are put into
practice the crisis that you were trying
to deal with or that your that was
hanging over your head ukraine will be
long gone putin will be out of power
there'll be a new structure in ukraine
and uh but we will have uh embedded a
whole bunch of high carbon
activities which will be with us for
decades so that's not the way to make
policy
and yet the government would say laura
they're still on track to meet what are
very ambitious targets they say and part
of their plans in response to the
ukraine crisis are to talk about
increasing the amount of wind power the
amount of hydrogen the amount of nuclear
and the amount of solar
but i think there's also a big push from
people within the government to not just
be going for that but also be going for
new oil and gas exploration quasi
quarting is a prime example of someone
who is really supportive of new
exploration using that as an excuse and
to be producing more of that
domestically and there's a bit of irony
there because of course he took on the
role that alok sharma left to become
full-time cop 26 president and now he is
taking up that role and pushing for more
oil and gas explosion which is not
within reaching 1.5 or limiting 1.5 we
know that the international energy
agency said we need to be moving away
from that and it's really frustrating to
see that disagreement hypocrisy those
challenges that we are facing from
different members of senior government
disagreeing with one another and pushing
for their own agendas well yeah and that
those that back it say that it still can
happen and and the government reaches
targets don't they um and now
what about cop 27 it's coming up in
november there's more pressure this time
around for countries to
come forward with with plans to meet
targets does that give you
source of optimism looking ahead
i think one thing that um shouldn't be
understated as this
nature of the success the cop 26 was um
very significant um
change in the attitude of the
international community was achieved and
some very important
milestones some of which you mentioned
so that's very positive the key point in
uh the trajectory of cops is maintaining
the momentum from present cop presidency
currently the united kingdom to cop
presidency
egypt next um and that handover is
absolutely critical to implementation
so we know that there's a a lot of um
very detailed work that's going on to
implement uh the
paris uh the uh glasgow commitments
different of the glasgow commitments and
that's ongoing it's absolutely essential
though that the handover is strong and
supportive and that the uk which i'm
sure it will uh continues to uh support
its egyptian colleagues in that okay
let's move on to our next topic shall we
because uh the big plastic count is
underway but will it do any good the
message doesn't seem to necessarily have
got through and navraj we were saying
earlier that the uk is second only to
the us in terms of our levels of plastic
pollution
why do you think that is why do we have
this bad record in this country
it's quite shocking isn't it um
it's
i think
part of the reason why we're finding it
very difficult to wean ourselves off
plastic
is the very close relationship between
the petrochemicals sector and government
so
um
we saw over the weekend for example in a
slightly different but similar context
over um food and obesity that the
government
the slightest push from industry results
from commitments that it has made about
um
you know changing the way that um
food is advertised and
is advertised
we're seeing um you know enormous
pushback from the uh sector both the uh
businesses usual um agro sector and the
petrochemicals industry which provides
the packaging to any change at all um
and
you know the relationship between
government and those sectors is so
intimate that this particular government
um is unwilling to take any particular
um
any sort of decisive action on the issue
so there's a real political lock-in
problem here
whatever you think of that relationship
laura is this really about
supermarkets making sure that they
demand that their suppliers use less
plastic and then it makes it easier for
consumers to avoid it too they have to
because why are we the second biggest
consumer or you know polluter of plastic
because we have to buy it because that's
all we are provided with when you walk
into a supermarket if you want something
that's plastic free good luck trying to
find it so we need supermarkets and
businesses as well to be pushing for it
we saw boots the retailer the kind of
pharmacy retailer say that they are
going to stop selling wet wipes with
plastic in it they are the biggest
seller of wet wipes with plastic in it
in the uk they represent about 15 of
sales so that is a business that just
recently has decided to push for that
change and we need to see more of that
because i agree that the government are
too slow but we do need policy change
but we also need brands and you know
corporations to step up and help us out
because as consumers we are really
restricted with what we can buy and you
know i'm going to be taking part in the
count and i think it's going to be a big
wake up for me and many other people but
that's also going to sit with a lot of
guilt and a lot of guilt which i don't
really know where to place because often
you try your hardest but you are really
limited with what you can buy never
actually think that's right or can
consumers do more themselves
very briefly if you can i don't think
that it's fair to dump the
responsibility of these sorts of issues
on consumers i think that's there are
mechanisms that we're familiar with and
say electronic waste where you put place
an obligation on the entity that
produces that waste to take it back and
to recycle or reuse or indeed not to
produce it in the first place
those sorts of producer obligations i
think are a far more uh reliable and
equitable solution to the plastic
problem rather than
requiring consumers to take the
initiative when as was just said
consumers have very few choices in this
matter okay we must leave it there
navraj and laura always good to get your
thoughts thanks very much indeed for
joining us tonight
thank you
and that's it from me thanks for
watching i'll see you next time
[Music]
you